hello everyone welcome to microsoft
research summit 2021st
my name is yuo chen i'm a principal
researcher in max research today i'm
going to talk transformer efficiency
from model compression to training
associations
we know transformer models have been
dominated in
air in recent years model like birth dbt
and the recent vision transformers have
been achieved a lot of success in
several domains including the
competition nature language processing
and speech recognition
one of the challenges of
is a computational efficiency
usually it's required lots of large
model and a lot more training stats
however how to make the
chamfer model transformer models more
efficient is one of the biggest
challenges to
to make it into real applications
my team have been working on the
transformer efficiency from 2019 we have
working on several
kinds of topics like the model
compressions to make us model
uh smaller and also we do
something called efficiency training
like birthday inflation training and dbt
three effects in fact tuning
today uh my talk will come most of those
topics
the first techniques we use for motor
compression is the knowledge
distributions
it's just naturally reduced the number
of layers in models for example we have
very light models and
or brace modes with
25 transfer layers and 12 transfer
layers you can reduce
them to
smaller uh layers transformers like a
six layer birds and three layer birds
another techniques we use called the
pruning
for transformers
uh we have two type of pruning the first
one is just you did for
uh xian and ostm called unstructured
pruning naturally prunes
the neurons in transformers
another uh pruning called structural
pruning
this spatulas for transformers
uh for we will
reduce the number of turning hats and
the dimension of the mmp layers also
some like q a k n
layers in transformers
which
reduce the
transformer structurally
i'm i'm starting to record the first
work we did for knowledge distillations
called the pkd
patient knowledge destinations
uh for pkd we follow the traditional uh
knowledge staging framework
which have two laws like
the task specific laws
to
make a prediction accurate and the
training examples and also we have this
called the uh student teacher laws which
just mimic the
teachers uh student
behavior with the teacher models
specifically for
uh
models like transformers which have a
deep transform layers we have another
loss called the intermediate uh measure
loss to measure intermediate
uh behavior between the teacher model
and the skeleton models
this true uh
type of immediate layers calculations
which we have called scape just due to
student and teacher model skip layer to
match them together and also we have the
last
type called pid to match the last layer
of the teacher and student model
empirically you find this they work
better than last
in the results you can see that on
different uh training center we find the
patient decisions actually works better
than logistics
also
uh in the glute benchmark we saw
uh you you have a six layer pkd and the
three layer really which are very close
to the baseline
of the bird's travel layer models
after pkd uh we are going to
to now transfer to another
topic which is following up work for pkd
called accordia contractual
distillations and intermediate
representations
uh the difference
between pid and accordion is just how
you measure the intermediate loss
all know that in the pkd we use l2 norm
to match the intermediate representation
between teacher model and the student
models but actually autonomy is the good
measure
for the hidden states
instead in kodia we use something called
the contractual loss for
to match the intermediate layers which
are just
you have the intermediate layer of ttr
student modeled and to
match them use the officially like info
and say you lost
so you can do this for uh fine tuning
yeah i also do this for pro training and
just a pro training take more time
and in the results you'll see you can
say on the glue uh kodi of functioning
and kodi pro training actually better
than the pkd and once you have like a
combined uh titanium per training
accordion you can even show a better
performance
than any other base size
after we do compression and pruning i
also think about the of the efficiency
fine tuning or efficient training
the worker called early birds actually
uh we will have done for burn models
the idea comes from the location
hypothesis which assume that you can get
the
sparse the network at the beginning
of the of the trainings and also we
follow another word called the early
bird tickets which we can do this in
structural race
we
use network naming to reduce the
number of returning head on mlp layers
to structure from the both models
after that
we have models but the same number of
like
uh
training
data so can reduce the number of
training airport and number training
iterations to further reduce the
functioning or training
time
in a result you can say in the
functional stage we can reduce 40 to 45
time streaming uh
and achieve a very similar performance
than baseline models also this can this
objective is held for the
uh
for the uh
the prone for training stage after we do
several things for our pe also do one
things for our vision transformers which
is very hard during recently for hitting
transmog first first we did this
dynamically
training to training to further reduce
the pruning time and also we do
something called model plus data code
explorations to reduce both both model
and data parameters
this is the framework for uh
svet
and you can see we do structural pruning
and unstructuring also the data pruning
in the results we can say different
pruning will give a very similar problem
than baseline while saving 30 to 40
training time or
the inference time
finally you can say stamina we show for
we do the data corresponding
the future workings will several parts
first we are very interested in gpd3
which uh we think is the major pain to
uh to do
for applied to real work we need to
compress and also we'll do some neuron
actual search and jointly work through
combining phrone and contagion for
different uh data not just the lp
version but something like multi models
uh that's that's also my work thank you
and if you have any questions you can
ask